[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARIEL ALTMAN: So tell
us about your journey.
How did you know you
wanted to be a doctor
and that this whole path
was really your calling?
TAZ BHATIA: You
know, I always say
it was an accidental journey.
I don't think anything was
super intentional until maybe
more recently.
But the whole point of
the path of being a doctor
really began when I was a child.
And we took a trip to India--
my parents are Indian.
And we went to Kolkata, which
is a very busy bustling city
in India.
And I just remember
being stunned.
And I remember,
literally, getting up
from the airport all the
way into the city just
looking around.
It was my first trip there,
that I could remember.
And just being
shocked, stunned--
the poverty, the people, the
noise, the colors, the smells.
It was just overwhelming.
And there's so many things
I remember from that trip.
From meeting my family
for the first time--
or extended family--
to trying to speak Hindi
in the most terrible way
you can possibly imagine,
and also other stuff.
But the thing that
stuck for years
later was just people in
the street that were hurt.
They looked like
they needed care.
And something in
me at that age--
I was 10-- and it was just
like, I want to help people.
I want to do something.
So, it's very naive.
Everyone walks around saying
they want to help people
and they want to do something.
[INAUDIBLE] back as I
went through high school
and then as I got into college.
In college, I had doubts.
And I had moments
where I'm like,
I'm not sure if
medicine is for me.
I love science,
I love chemistry,
I love thinking
through all of that.
But I also love writing
and I love speaking.
And I was thinking maybe
more journalism, maybe
that's the way to go.
And at the end of the
day, I chose medicine
and embarked on that path
and that journey-- which
consumed me, quite honestly.
And left journalism behind,
left writing behind.
Didn't read a
book, didn't write,
didn't do anything for years.
And it's just funny
how life works out.
Journalism found me again.
So that was sort of the
path to becoming a doctor
and to entering this field.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Absolutely.
That's so interesting.
And not only are you a
doctor, but you've really,
in a profound way, combined
Western medicine with Eastern
medicine.
So can you talk a
little bit about what's
guided you to not just do the
traditional medical route,
but explore this whole
other world that may not
be as familiar to most people?
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah, so that
also is an accidental journey.
I never intended to jump into
the world of Eastern medicine
or integrative medicine.
I was a hardcore
doctor, quite honestly.
I loved procedures,
I loved adrenaline.
I wanted to be an ICU doctor.
I interviewed across the
country for ICU fellowships.
And the only reason I
detoured from that was there
was a lot of stuff going on in
our family, back in Atlanta.
And I was like, I really need
to be home for a year or two,
settle all that stuff down.
Let me go back to Atlanta.
And I took a job in urgent care.
And so from urgent care, I got
recruited into the emergency
room.
And the emergency room,
again, as high adrenaline.
You're doing everything,
you're seeing everything,
you're doing procedures.
And you see everything
under the sun
and you meet every type
of person under the sun.
So I liked it, I
actually really loved it.
So that's the type
of doctor I was.
But, unfortunately, the years
of medical school, the years
of ER work were taking a toll.
And I didn't even realize it.
I wasn't even conscious
or aware of it.
I was completely
disconnected from what
was happening with me.
I was more interested in
what I was accomplishing
or what I was doing.
And the kind of silent whispers
that I always talk about.
Like, you don't
feel quite right,
your joints are
hurting a little bit,
you're starting to gain
weight and you can't really
explain it.
Everything that was kind of just
very silent, kind of murmuring
under the surface for
years, started to crescendo.
To the point where I was losing
hair-- it was noticeable.
I was gaining a
significant amount
of weight, had terrible acne.
I didn't feel good.
I would get dressed in the dark.
I was just so embarrassed to
try to put myself together.
And then, I still
didn't connect.
I still didn't connect
that something was wrong
and I needed to do something.
It's just I was so in my
head most of the time.
And it was finally
a couple of things.
It was my mom--
who was really proud of
my original Indian hair,
because I had the best
hair in the family.
And was absolutely devastated
that now, like, half of it
was gone.
And it was my now-husband, who
we were dating at the time,
was just like, something's
wrong with you.
You need to get
checked out know.
He goes, I don't care, but I
feel like something's wrong.
It was my patients.
Because the ER, at some point,
is still primary care nowadays.
So there are patients
that would come in
and had seen me for
a few years, and they
were staring up at my scalp.
They weren't really looking at
me or paying attention to me.
And so it was kind
of those three things
that motivated me to start this
journey of trying to understand
what was happening.
What was happening with my
health, what did I need to do?
And that began my journey
for finding answers.
And that journey
didn't go really well.
It was so frustrating and
not to jump ahead, but I've--
to deal with my
mother-in-law right now, who
has a new diagnosis of cancer.
And back in that
conventional medicine world.
And that journey hasn't
changed for people.
It's just as hellish
as I remember it being.
And I went from doctor to
doctor trying to get answers,
trying to get solutions and
didn't really get anywhere.
Went to the, quote unquote,
"best doctors in the city."
Was willing to travel
to get answers--
nothing.
And then finally got
put on a medication
that one of the side
effects of the medication
was that it dropped
my blood pressure.
And I'm telling the story
not just to tell you
what happened to me, but also
that explain how disconnected I
was, and I was a physician.
So I'm put on this
medication, I'm
following what I was told to do.
I'm not paying attention
or digging into the fact
that this might drop
my blood pressure.
My blood pressure
is already low.
Shame on me for that.
I already have this knowledge.
So anyhow, my blood pressure
dropped dramatically one day
while I was driving.
And so I got into a wreck.
I could have hit somebody else,
I could have hit another car.
I could have died.
And so that was sort
of just a jolt, like--
ARIEL ALTMAN: A wake up, yeah.
TAZ BHATIA: Like,
what am I doing?
And so, that began a
search for answers.
That began going home
that day and being like,
I've got to figure
something else out.
And I've got to do it on my own.
There's really nobody else
who's going to do this for me.
There's no prints coming in,
and there's no magic solution,
there's no one pill.
So I just started studying.
So I did everything I
could get my hands on.
And it began with a weekend
course in holistic medicine.
And then that became wanting
to be certified in nutrition.
And that became wanting
to learn Chinese medicine.
So I flew to San Francisco and
became a licensed acupuncturist
and studied Chinese
herbal medicine.
I learned about Ayurvedic, which
was a little bit of my roots,
and got reintroduced to that.
And then finally did the
integrative medicine fellowship
with Dr. Weil,
which is in Arizona.
And so, I spent two years
going through that program.
And that kind of finally--
I finished that
program, I think was
2008-- that gave
me the confidence
to put all these little
pieces I had back together,
in terms of maybe taking
care of somebody else.
And all the information I
gathered up until that point,
I had fixed myself.
It took me a good two years,
but I had fixed myself.
But then it was everybody
else asking questions.
Like, what'd you do?
Well, how did that happen?
What was the solution there?
You know, what herb
would you take?
Would you do
acupuncture for this?
So all those questions, and
then finishing the fellowship,
that was kind of the
moment where like, hey,
I might have something here.
I might be able to
help a few people.
So that got me into the
world of Eastern medicine,
integrative medicine,
functional medicine,
nutrition-- all these
different fields
that you hear about today.
But that was my entry into it.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Absolutely.
No, really interesting journey.
I think wellness is such
a buzz word everywhere.
And it's kind of
just the new fad.
So how do you define
wellness and how do you
break down some of those
stereotypes or misconceptions
that are out in the media and
in our everyday lives today?
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah, I
feel like wellness
is such a used term, now.
Everybody's talking
about wellness,
it's in our vernacular.
Which I think is great.
I mean, I think it's fantastic
that we've shifted from disease
management to wellness.
I think that's a huge
accomplishment culturally,
so that's fantastic.
The wellness means different
things to different people.
And it depends on who
you're talking to.
I remember I'm coming
from this vantage
point and this perspective of
having all this different types
of training under
my belt, including
conventional medical training.
And so when I sit back and I
think about what does wellness
mean to me, and what does
it mean for my patients,
or for my center, or
for anyone that I touch,
it's really cumulative.
It's additive, there's not one
factor that defines wellness.
And so it's really
the accumulation
of a number of different things.
And I would start with energy,
like where's your energy?
If you have good energy.
Your emotional landscape.
I mean, I think the further
I get along-- it's funny,
it's like, I know
so much chemistry
and I know so much
physiology, and I'm
sure we'll talk
about all of that.
But the further
I get along, it's
like I'm understanding how
powerful our emotions are,
how powerful our sense
of connection is.
That's a part of wellness, too.
I think it is chemistry.
It's your nutrition, it's your
biologies, your physiology.
What's your gut doing?
Do you have inflammation?
It's all of those
things, as well.
And then it is about community,
and family, and support,
and spirituality.
All of those things
define wellness.
And that is the reason I
think that so many peoples sit
in my exam rooms, or my offices,
or talk to me when I'm out.
And they're like, well,
I don't understand.
I ate this way, I
did this, I did that.
Why did I get X, Y, and Z?
It's because, again, it's
cumulative, it's additive.
And it can feel overwhelming
to try to tackle all of that.
But unless we start to sit back
and understand that it's all
influencing each other--
I had an expert tell me recently
that a hamburger on vacation
is metabolized completely
differently than a hamburger
when you're stressed out, or you
might be eating it right now.
So, again, it's so
cumulative and so additive.
And we have to understand how
all those pieces come together.
And the beauty of Eastern
systems of medicine
is that they stress
that from the get go.
It wasn't just take this herb.
It was like, well, what's
the rest of your life doing?
And then trying to understand
how to put all that together.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Love it.
I love it.
So, obviously Western
medicine hat, then.
What would be like
a hack or something
that you know is a general tip
that you could give to some
of our viewers or audiences?
I know that our
worlds are so crazy,
but if you could do one
thing today, what would
you suggest doing?
TAZ BHATIA: Oh my gosh.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Besides buying
Super Woman right now?
TAZ BHATIA: Well, I think the
first thing I would stress--
and it's funny because I
think my answer's changed
over the years.
But I think the very
first thing I would stress
is the importance of being
connected to yourself.
I think that's the most
important thing you can do--
to not ignore yourself.
I think most people, and
most women, in particular,
ignore the soft
and silent whispers
that we hear on any given day.
They'll ignore the fact that I'm
tired more days out of the week
than I'm not.
Or that something's hurting,
or that my hair's falling,
or this joint's bothering me.
Or why am I gaining
weight or losing weight--
either direction--
more so than I ever
have in the past?
Or why am I suddenly getting
more anxiety or depression?
I think we collectively
ignore those things.
And I think the most
important thing,
before you start any
health or wellness journey,
is to understand how to
get connected back to you.
I would say that's
the first thing.
And there's so many
different ways to do that.
I mean that's a really
big blanket statement.
But it's everything from
just adopt one habit
that you could do every day.
Maybe you journal every morning,
maybe you pray everyday,
maybe you meditate.
Maybe you go for
a walk in nature.
But whatever it is, have that
conversation with yourself
in whatever format you want to.
Because that will bring
you back to yourself.
So that would be my first, kind
of foundational starting point.
Then we can keep building
from there, if you want.
ARIEL ALTMAN: No, it's great.
You know, Googlers are often
high-achieving individuals,
are constantly
plugged in, dealing
with many different
levels of stress.
So what do you do to unplug?
Or any suggestions
for when you feel
like you're on that
brink of burnout or you
feel something coming along.
Besides getting in
touch with yourself,
what are some things that
maybe you like to do?
TAZ BHATIA: I think it's
so easy to get burned out
when you're a high
achiever because you
want to accomplish a lot.
I still want to accomplish
a lot, I'm far from done.
But you have to
watch your energy
and you have to watch,
kind of, your boundaries.
And I think it's so hard to
do because there's always
that goal or that next milestone
that you're trying to get to
or trying to accomplish.
So, again, I think one of
the things in your schedule--
put the breaks in.
I think you need to put in
breaks throughout the day.
Especially for you guys, right.
Because you guys are
on technology a lot.
And I think that in
itself is very draining.
We're learning more and more
about the effects of that
as we get further along.
But I think putting
those breaks in.
I would take three 10-minute
breaks throughout your workday
where you are forced
to get up, get away
from computers, cell phones,
iPads, all that other stuff.
Maybe walk outside the
building for just a little bit,
get fresh air.
It's amazing how just
fresh air and sunlight can
shift your energy very quickly.
So that's just a quick, easy
hack that you can do anywhere.
So those three 10-minute breaks.
I would also strongly advise--
this is so easy to
do, too-- but really
put in your schedule to block
maybe an hour to two hours
a week to do something
that lowers cortisol.
So that means you're
not running necessarily,
but you're walking, or
you're going for a swim,
or you're doing yoga.
Or maybe you're just in
nature for a period of time.
Or go ahead and schedule
that massage, or acupuncture,
or something along those lines.
Those are ways to recharge.
Because the biggest problem
with high achievers-- and I'd
be so curious to see what
everybody at Google tests
outs as in the Power Type plan.
But the biggest problem
with high achievers
is that they never take
time out to distress.
You're in high adrenaline
mode all the time.
And the problem
with high adrenaline
is, yes, you get stuff done.
But at some point, you're
going to crash and burn.
And that crash and burn comes
as, maybe, mild symptoms--
I'm just tired, it's hard to
get to work in the morning--
to things that are so severe.
Like I can't move, I'm
depressed, or things like that.
So you never want to
get to that place.
So putting those
natural breaks in.
10 minutes throughout the day,
two to three hours a week,
where you're doing
something that's
very different from your
job, but you're also
doing something that's
forcing you to lower cortisol.
Because that's the hormone that
you guys are at the most risk
for.
And that could be any of
the modalities that do that,
whether it's walking,
doing yoga, swimming, doing
acupuncture, doing massage.
Any of those things
that force you to relax.
So those are probably my
strongest tips for that.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Awesome, love it.
And I know you said that
a really important piece
of this wellness journey
is knowing yourself.
TAZ BHATIA: Yes.
ARIEL ALTMAN: And
you've actually
developed a really
interesting way
to know yourself
a little bit more
through this idea
of Power Types.
So could you talk to us a little
bit about the different Power
Types and how you thought
of this whole methodology?
TAZ BHATIA: Yes, definitely.
So, again, I have all
this different types
of training under my belt--
Eastern medicine, Chinese,
Ayurvedic, nutrition.
And then at the
same time, I'm doing
conventional Western
medicine labs in our office.
I'm looking at hormone levels,
I'm looking at nutrient levels.
I'm getting real
data to match what
I'm seeing with the
other diagnostic systems.
And one of the
things I learned--
I continue, as I sit with
women, in particular-- even men.
There's probably a book
for men coming soon.
But even--
ARIEL ALTMAN: Get ready.
TAZ BHATIA: But for women in
particular, what I've noticed
is, again, this
loss of what to do.
They don't have a road map,
they don't have a plan.
And that's the question I get
asked over and over again.
It's classic, they'll
bring a bag of supplements,
or they'll bring five
books, or whatever.
Like, I don't know what to do.
Please tell me what to do.
And we're all different.
We're all unique,
we're all individual.
But as I was talking to women--
and I'm about 12,000 women
in, over the last decade
of seeing patients--
and you listen to them, and
you're hearing their stories,
and then you're
interpreting data--
the pattern started to line up.
And so, somebody who had
this medical condition
and this hormone imbalance
was also this Ayurvedic type,
this Chinese medicine
meridian imbalance,
this nutritional
deficiency, over here.
And I could start to see
them at a certain point
in the practice.
And then I started
to track them.
And I started to
write them down.
And when you start to write
them down and track them,
then you're like, oh my
gosh, there's something here.
We would have this powerful
prescriptive formula
for empowerment, really,
to help us all feel amazing
if we use the tools of both
and merge them together.
And we'd be able to understand,
OK, this is why I do this,
this is why I need
to eat this way.
So that's how the whole
concept of Power Typing began.
So it started with a
bunch of spreadsheets--
probably Google
spreadsheets, actually.
ARIEL ALTMAN: I was going to
say, are they Google Sheets?
TAZ BHATIA: Used lots
of Google spreadsheets
and entered a lot of data just
to track what was happening.
And then as I developed
the five types--
so these are five Power Types.
And they each have a distinct
way that they need to eat,
they need to move.
Their personalities tie into
it, their emotional tendencies
tie into that, as well.
There are supplements that
they might need, their hormone
imbalances.
So as I developed them, then
the next step was to name them.
And so the names, again,
I've stolen, literally,
from Eastern
systems of medicine.
So the five Power Types, just
to review them real quickly.
The first one is the Gypsy Girl.
And the Gypsy's my creative.
Super creative, some
of you may be Gypsies.
But have that Vata energy
from Ayurvedic medicine.
Have that sort of
adrenal issue where
they're more likely to
go into adrenal fatigue,
have anxiety, those
type of things.
So there's a whole
set of issues that
are both pros and cons that
come with being a Gypsy.
The second one is the Boss Lady,
and that's your high achiever.
That's your go getter,
your commander.
The Boss Lady is amazing.
We have a lot of
Boss Ladies we know,
and apparently there are
a lot of Boss Ladies that
are very high-achieving
women at work.
But the biggest problem
there, in Ayurvedic,
they're more Pitta.
And they hold all their stress
in their digestive system.
So the first thing
to go for a boss lady
is usually something
with their gut.
So, IBS, constipation,
reflux-- you name it.
But then that goes
on-- and this is where
modern science intersects.
We know that all inflammation
today begins in the gut.
We know that in science.
We're seeing that
when we do research
on the microbiome and all
that other good stuff.
Chinese medicine and
Ayurvedic medicine
had already talked about that.
So, again, if you knew
this ahead of time,
if you know your
Boss Lady and you
know that you're going
to hold your stress
in your digestive
system, then all the
more important to be on
the right diet for you
to protect against
inflammation, to protect
against as autoimmune
diseases, and things like that.
The next one is a blend and
that's what both of us are.
We're both Savvy Chicks.
And that's a blend of the
Gypsy and the Boss Lady.
So, part creative,
part go getter.
So at times, we're probably
lost somewhere in space,
and at other times
we're like go, go, go.
So it's a blend,
but then you have
the medical issues of both, and
the hormone patterns of both,
and the nutritional
needs of both.
I think after that it
was the Earth Mama.
And the Earth Mama
is the nurturer.
I would say it's the person
that's the center of a home
and the center of a family.
You guys probably
know an Earth Mama
around you or within
your own families.
But they are the worst about
establishing boundaries
and really attending
to their own needs.
They're usually worried
about everybody else.
And they define themselves
really through everybody else.
But there's a medical
consequence to that.
And that's what we
find with Earth Mamas,
they often have issues
with insulin resistance,
with diabetes, hypertension,
more cardiometabolic-type
issues.
They're the ones the most
likely to get depressed
because, again, they
don't have their own
foundation and self-worth.
So that's the Earth Mama.
And then the last one
is the Nightingale.
And the Nightingale is
that mission-oriented,
service-focused person
who just is about a higher
calling and a higher cause.
But again, to the point that
they sacrifice themselves.
And so they may be your
friend that's on mission trips
constantly.
And then it turns around
that they're getting, like,
pneumonia, and bronchitis, and
all these different illnesses
over and over again.
It typically taxes
their immune system.
That's the first thing
that goes for them.
So for them--
I've had a lot of Nightingales
in practice as well.
And it's always reminding them
that the mission is important,
but the mission is only
as good as they are.
So they've got to take the time
to rebuild their immune system.
And, again, there's a
diet that matches that.
They're supplements
that match that.
There's a certain
way they should move.
They should not be
running and doing
marathons, and all
that other stuff,
when they're in that
Nightingale phase.
So it's fascinating to help
women understand who they are,
see them do the plan, and
then see them make changes.
And then the other
important thing, though,
is as women, in particular,
at any given time,
we may be any one of
those power types.
We're going to shift.
We're hormonal creatures,
so we're going to shift.
We may have a phase
of our life where
we're full on Boss Ladies.
But then we may switch
and have a phase
where the Earth Mama, or
have a later phase where
the Nightingale.
All of that's irrelevant.
It's more important
for you just to connect
to who you are at
any given phase
so that you understand how
to take care of yourself
at that phase.
So, so many people when I
first came out with this
was, well, what's better?
Which is the best one?
Which is the best one to be?
I'm like, they're all good!
Every single one is good.
Is just that the
point of this was
to understand who
you are and really
put some thought into, hey, this
is who I am and therefore, this
is my roadmap.
And then once you have that
roadmap, for me, what I really
wanted in writing
this particular book
and developing the
Power Type formula,
is I wanted anyone who
touched it and picked it up
to begin that conversation
with themselves.
To begin to
understand themselves.
I'm not saying I have
all the answers in there,
for every aspect
of their health.
But I sure do have
a way for them
to at least begin that
road and that journey.
So that you don't
waste five or six
years like I did, feeling
bad about yourself,
not going for it
or doing everything
you're supposed to do.
You really are just
full-fledged ahead
being the superwoman
you're supposed to be.
I now firmly believe that.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Yeah, I love it.
And you got the Super Woman
title from your daughter,
right?
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah!
So, this was a fun story.
I had this concept already
in my head of types of women
and was tracking and doing
all that other stuff.
And I think it was--
we were on a car ride
with my daughter.
We just come from an
event where a lot of women
had come up to me that we know.
And had been making comments,
and she was with me.
And we get in the car
and we're driving.
And she's like, Mommy, you
need to write a book for women.
And I'm like, I do?
And she's like, yeah.
You need to write a book.
I go, well, what
would you write?
What would you call it?
And she's such an
old soul, but she's
like, you need to write a
book called Super Woman.
Because you're a super woman.
I feel like every woman
I meet is always talking
about how you're a super woman.
So maybe you need to help
everybody else be a super woman
because I just see you as Mom.
So she actually came
up with the title.
I'm like, you're right.
That's a really great idea.
So we called the book
The Super Woman Rx.
And I dedicated the
book to her because it
is her idea and her title.
And then she helped
me, actually,
too with the Power
Type names, as well.
And she took the test.
She was only eight, I think,
when I started the concept.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Wow.
TAZ BHATIA: And she
was nine, almost 10,
when the book was published.
But she still goes in
and takes the test.
I'm like, half these questions
aren't relevant to you.
She's like, it's OK.
I already figured it out.
I'm a Gypsy.
[LAUGHING]
It's hilarious.
ARIEL ALTMAN: That's awesome.
TAZ BHATIA: But
yeah, she's a cutie.
ARIEL ALTMAN: I
love it, I love it.
So we're at Google, right?
We're all about technology
and the digital world.
How do you think about
digital technology
and how it integrates
with medicine today?
Or even the things that
you do on a daily basis--
or your practice, or
how you help women.
TAZ BHATIA: How much
time do you have?
[LAUGHING]
ARIEL ALTMAN: Five minutes.
TAZ BHATIA: Well, to do.
So, I am the biggest
technological idiot
you've ever met in you life.
So my tech support,
when I was like 21,
was my 9-year-old sister.
So I never thought
I'd have to spend
as much time thinking
about technology,
but it is a reality of today.
And it has absolutely
impacted our business.
It's impacted the practice.
It's impacting patient
care, quite honestly.
So technology is a must.
And I have forcefully had to
immerse myself in that world
and try to understand how
this piece of the equation
fits into what I'm doing.
And here's what I think.
I think that
technology is amazing.
We need technology to track
that-- to track our data,
to track our numbers.
To help remind us of
habits and behaviors.
And to help with resources.
We absolutely need
technology for that.
And I think one
of the limitations
that even I'm experiencing
with this type of medicine
that we're doing, is that
there's not a central place
to get this information.
It's not coming out.
So a lot of it's having to come
out of my mouth or something
that I write.
It would be amazing to have this
stuff available in real time
for women so they understand.
OK, I just told you
you're a Gypsy Girl,
now go figure out-- here all
the other resources you need.
And we continually update it.
So I know that there's a need
for that type of technology
that is resourceful, data
tracking, motivating,
educational.
There's that.
From a practice standpoint,
what we have noticed--
and we're actually
developing our own platform
because it's such an issue.
Is that to do the
medicine that I'm doing,
there's not the
technology out there.
So it slows me down from
a practice standpoint
and it prevents my growth.
So for medicine to
really move forward,
we've got to have
systems that integrate
all that information--
ARIEL ALTMAN: Import it, yeah.
TAZ BHATIA: --that put all
the information together
and really help patients
with the full picture
of their health.
I defined wellness
for you earlier.
Well, that technology needs
to match that definition.
And it needs to be
able to show people
this is a cumulative, additive
properties of your health.
This is what your
wellness looks like.
And it's taking all
of that into account.
And then from a operational
standpoint, with a practice
and with a business, it needs
to mirror that, as well.
So that's where we are.
We're trying to develop a
platform so that we can then
take this medicine, make it more
efficient, make it scalable.
And then allow it to grow beyond
just Atlanta, the few centers
that we have in Atlanta.
And be able to grow beyond.
So that women everywhere
can have access to it.
And then same thing with
the super women theory.
We want technology
there so that women
can continue to grow in
that process of having
that conversation
with themselves
and understanding who they are.
Because I love the
books, I love writing,
but not that many
people read anymore.
[LAUGHING]
They want quicker
information, they
want to download it faster.
So the book is a great
foundational step,
but the next step is
probably technology.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Absolutely.
Super interesting.
And I know you mentioned
this idea of expansion.
TAZ BHATIA: Yes.
ARIEL ALTMAN: So what's next
for you, for the center?
What are you most excited about
in the next six to 12 months,
maybe in your personal
life, the center's space,
but also in the medical world?
What excites you and gets
you out of bed every morning?
TAZ BHATIA: Oh my
gosh, there's so much.
I think that, in
the medical world,
it's fascinating to
continue to watch
the intersection of
genetics, food and nutrition,
and all these other
data points that we've
been talking about for years.
How they intersect
and are really
redefining what prevention is
and redefining what healthy is.
So the conventional world
needs some time to catch up.
But what's super exciting is
seeing the integrative worlds
and the functional
medicine worlds really
start to gain their spot.
Really start to come
into the forefront
and lead some of
these conversations
on what prevention really means.
What does healthy really mean.
And for the longest
time, there was just
a one-liner, flat
definition of that.
I think the other
thing that gets me out
of bed in the morning, just
from a medical standpoint,
is I'm a huge believer
in family wellness.
I've lived in a situation
where the family was not well.
And the center of that
family is always the woman.
So that's why I decided
to start with women.
Because when the
woman is not healthy,
it reverberates out into
her children, her husband,
her extended family,
her community, her city.
So, I think it's so
important to shift culture.
We have to create
strong families.
And we have to create really
unified, healthy families.
And it starts with a woman.
So what gets me excited, and
the challenged, quite honestly,
is understanding that when
it comes to women's health,
there are miles, and miles,
and miles of work to do,
journeys to travel.
Because we historically have
gaslight women's health issues.
Women's health issues were
always brushed to the side
because it was a male-dominated
field when in Western medicine
was born.
So to really change what's
happening within a family,
I've got to change what's
happening with women.
And if I can change what's
happening with women,
then I can turn around
and impact that family.
So that's what gets me
out of bed in the morning,
is knowing that that's sort of
the framework from which I'm
functioning.
And I love it.
And to this day,
there's not a day
that I walk into my practice
and I don't learn something,
or I speak and I don't learn
something from somebody I meet.
And it's just such a
fascinating journey.
As far as the practice
goes, and as far as I go,
we're just going to continue
to grow, and scale, and expand.
We're trying to,
again, use technology
to make this old
way of doing things
better and more efficient.
Because we're now in a culture
that we can't sit and talk
for two hours about something.
So how do we create--
this take this old
system of medicine,
integrate it with the
newer modern medicine.
But then at the
same time, preserve
the character, the flavor,
but also make it efficient
and run the way it's
supposed to run?
So that's our challenge.
So that keeps me
going in the center.
And technology is a big
part of that conversation.
So six to 12 months
from now I hope that we
have our technology wrapped.
I hope that we are opening
and launching, maybe
here in New York, in
LA, and other places
around the country.
And as far as I go,
I hope I continue
to do the work that needs to be
done to get this message out,
louder and louder.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Well
that's amazing.
TAZ BHATIA: Thank you.
ARIEL ALTMAN: What
a great mission.
And we're here to
help and support.
So we'll open up the
floor for questions.
AUDIENCE: As you
were talking, it
makes me think a lot about
the, sort of, obesity epidemic
in this country.
I'm just wondering, where
does that all connect in here?
And how do you think
about bringing that
to folks who probably need it?
TAZ BHATIA: That's
such a great--
AUDIENCE: More than, maybe,
some of us, or some others.
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I think the
obesity epidemic
has happened for a number
of different reasons.
Probably the number one
reason is, honestly,
our food sourcing and the
production of our food.
The more and more
we dig into obesity,
we're understanding
that a lot of what
was used over the last 30,
40 years between additives,
and fillers, and preservatives,
and things like that
have been hormone disruptors
and have contributed
to that conversation.
So when it comes
to obesity, again,
if we can educate a
family on the right way
to eat in a way that's not--
everyone has a preconceived
notion that eating healthy
is expensive.
So if we can help families
learn to navigate that terrain
so they understand how
to make healthy choices.
And, again, it usually
starts with the woman.
Because the woman's
doing the cooking,
the shopping, the buying.
So the more empowered you can
make the woman of the family,
typically it'll go
out into the children
and into the adult other
adults of the family
to help with the obesity crisis.
We just are also a culture
of over-consumption,
quite honestly.
You know we're eating way
more than we need to eat.
And that goes to our children
and it goes to us as adults,
as well.
So helping people understand
what normal consumption is,
I think is a big part of it.
And that's where the whole
conversation on food waste
also comes up.
Because we waste
so much food, too.
So the obesity
conversation, I know
there's been a huge spotlight
with movement and activity.
I'm going to push back on that
and say it's honestly 80% food
and it's only 20% activity.
And I think that's
where maybe we
have the conversation
wrong to a certain extent.
I do also think that technology
is an issue for obesity
in the future.
How are we going to take this
tool, this amazing tool that we
have, of being connected to
anyone, anywhere in the world,
and get information
at any given moment.
But at the same time create
some boundaries and parameters
so that people are
using it in a way that
is productive and proactive
and not working against them?
So the biggest thing I've
seen in pediatrics, which
is another one of my
medical loves, so to speak,
but is that children
don't have the boundaries
to navigate technology.
And adults don't
have the education
to help them navigate
those boundaries.
And, again, as much
as I know, I've
struggled with my two children.
And what's normal,
what's not normal, what's
OK.
So I think technology,
I think food, first.
I think our food is
the biggest problem.
I think looking at
technology and looking
at how children are trapped
in rooms a lot of the times.
They're not outside.
I think the over scheduling
of families is an issue, too.
I mean all of these
things are factors that
play into obesity, for sure.
And then when it comes to
different socioeconomic groups,
helping them with
food deserts and areas
that aren't getting
high-quality food.
There's so many-- I could
talk forever on this,
and I'll probably need to stop.
But there's so
many great studies.
Like if you give a young child--
any socioeconomic status--
if you give them salads,
and healthy vegetables,
and all that other stuff, they
will continue to choose that.
But the minute you introduce
a high-salt high-fat food,
their palate changes.
And when they did
a study comparing
lower socioeconomic
kids and their parents,
and giving them food
choices, the kids actually
chose the healthier foods.
The parents had been so
acclimated to a certain taste
that they chose
the junkier foods.
So a lot of palate
training is happening.
There's a lot that needs
to take place there.
So I think it's
education, again.
I think it's change.
It's got to be change in
our industry and our food
processing.
And then creating environments
where children can thrive
and adults can thrive as well.
ARIEL ALTMAN: That's
super interesting.
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah.
ARIEL ALTMAN: What's
your view on sugar?
That's another hot topic.
TAZ BHATIA: [LAUGHING]
So sugar is probably,
maybe the number one culprit.
Sugar and salt, I think
those are the two things.
And all the different
forms of it.
So, high fructose corn syrup,
all the different sweeteners
and fillers, and Splenda,
and all that other stuff,
is probably the
number one thing.
There is sugar in everything.
So sugar is probably
one of the biggest
culprits for the
obesity crisis, I think.
And when you go back and
look at food manufacturing
and you look at what changed.
There are a couple
of things that
changed 30 to 40 years ago.
The amount of sugar and
sweeteners is one of them.
The amount of additives
and salt is another.
The third is the use of certain
pesticides and chemicals
in our food manufacturing.
Those are probably your
three biggest changes.
ARIEL ALTMAN: And I go
into a grocery store.
And sometimes I'm like,
should I get organic,
should I not get organic?
Should I get that
type, that type?
What are your tips,
or what do you
do when you go food shopping?
TAZ BHATIA: So what we do--
I mean, we're the
majority organic.
But I know that
that's hard to sustain
and it's hard to maintain.
But I think it's, again,
the dirtiest foods.
The Dirty Dozen,
like on the EWG.
If you want, it's the
Environmental Working Group's
list, if you want to
familiarize yourself.
Those are worth buying organic.
But here's the challenge.
Even people that are eating
organic and buying organic,
there's so much
cross-contamination,
that you're still getting
exposed to different chemicals,
different pesticides,
different things.
So, again, that's
why being proactive
and being in the sort of
integrative functional space I
think is so critical.
Because it's hard to
control your environment.
Even when you're being so
conscious, and so careful,
and so deliberate
about your choices.
Sometimes it's
very difficult just
to control the environment.
And our needs are different
than what they were.
We had an infectious disease
problem, maybe 50 years ago.
We had different medical issues.
The medical issues
of tomorrow are
going to be environmentally
induced, they're
going to be toxicity
issues, they're going
to be diseases of inflammation.
Those are the diseases
of today and tomorrow.
That's why cancer's
on the rise, that's
why autoimmune disease
is on the rise.
So it's just so hard
to navigate the space
that I think that the more
you know what your body
chemistry is doing, and you're
being as proactive as you can
to support it, you're going
to have a better sort of come
all the way through.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Yeah.
No, absolutely.
Super, super interesting.
I think we had a question.
Yes?
TAZ BHATIA: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: First, thank you
so much for being here.
I read the book and loved it.
And what I really
loved is that you
made it so accessible
for someone who doesn't
have a medical background.
And I would love to hear any
tips or recommendations you
have, given there's just so much
information out there on health
and wellness and medicine.
And you've mentioned,
with being a doctor
and having a medical
background, being
disconnected from some of that.
So and recommendations
you have just, like,
navigating the noise and
knowing what's a credible source
and where we should
spend our time.
TAZ BHATIA: Definitely.
I mean, I think that's
probably the hardest
part, is trying to find
the information that you
can rely on.
I think your first step is
to find a medical provider
that you can have these
conversations with,
quite honestly.
I think there there's a lot of
noise in the wellness space.
So, again, turning-- not that
I'm trying to our own horns.
But turning to the integrative
and functional community where
there's so many great
providers coming along
and they have worked
really hard at getting
the conventional training,
but also getting the training
on the other side, so to speak.
And understanding how--
where those worlds intersect.
I think that's probably
your most efficient way
of going about it.
Because after that, if you're
trying to navigate, like, well,
I read this article over here.
And it's to take this.
And I did this over here,
and it said to take that.
It's really difficult. That's
why I wrote the Super Woman
Rx, honestly.
Because I know
that there are not
integrative and functional
medicine providers everywhere,
but at least that's a start.
At least if you can understand--
and even in the book, remember,
there are labs for you to check.
There's all that information for
you to advocate for yourself,
when you walk into
the doctor's office.
But I still firmly believe--
and as many different
types of providers
as there are in the
health and wellness space.
I still really believe
that the physician
has to sit at that table and has
to help direct those decisions.
Because the physician ultimately
has the breadth and depth
of understanding of
how one decision will
play into another and what sort
of all of that relationship is.
So I think finding
a strong provider
who can help you navigate
information will be helpful.
And then once you
get the main ideas--
this is you.
You understand you.
Then do your digging,
and your research,
and anything else you want
to do, and read other books.
To gain information
under that main idea.
It's almost like
writing a chapter.
Come out with that main
thesis about yourself.
And then underneath that, you
can develop things out more.
Because you may then find
things that particular provider
or doctor didn't know.
And that's OK, it's
just digging deeper.
But the confusion
comes when, well,
do I need to eat
for my adrenals,
or do I need to eat for insulin?
Or do I need to go paleo,
or vegan, or gluten free?
That's where the
confusion starts and gets
so frustrating to navigate.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Yeah.
Great question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This is kind
of following up to that.
But I think you're in
the unique position
of having both Western and
Eastern medical background
and training.
What do you see as
the future of sort
of scaling these Eastern
medical practices
across Western medicine
across the country when
so many people are-- it's not
widely accepted, as you said.
And it might not
be as easy for--
it might not be
easy for everyone
or accessible to find someone
who's trained in both Eastern
and medical.
And if someone isn't sure where
to start with their own Eastern
medical research
and how to apply it
to Western, what do you see
as the future and the best way
to go about that?
TAZ BHATIA: So, the
future of the industry,
if you're asking about
that, first, of merging
Eastern and Western
medicine is my passion.
I really feel like
it's my purpose.
How do we get this out there?
How do we get it in the
hands of more people?
And there are different
ways to do that.
And there are different ways
to bring it into medicine
and change the medical model.
So there are many of us,
I'm not the only one.
But there are many
of us who want
to change the medical
model and want to see it
more accessible to more folks.
So I think that is
a definite goal.
And something that you asked
me earlier, what gets me out
of bed in the morning?
I mean, I think that's something
that sort of motivates me.
For you, that it's
worthless, right?
Because you're like, OK great.
You're going to work on
this for the next 20 years.
Meanwhile, I have to
live the next 20 years.
For you, I think it's,
again, pooling together
as many different resources
from the two systems.
Or finding providers
like me, there
are others like me,
that do do consults.
Sometimes you don't have to be
necessarily here in the city,
they're remote, or things
like that that help
provide you at least
foundational framework
for doing that.
And again, the intention of the
book was to do that for you.
To help you begin
that conversation.
And then, again,
underneath that,
once you understand who you
are and what your needs are,
go ahead get the opinions from
a Chinese medicine practitioner,
from an Ayurvedic
practitioner, from your doctor.
And merge that
information together.
But ultimately, you want to
find someone to guide you
through that process.
Because it can get very
overwhelming and confusing
to get information from
so many different places.
So I think it's--
read the book and see
if that helps you.
I would say try to find
a practitioner that
is well versed in both
to give you some guidance
and direction.
And then begin your journey
of exploring different aspects
of your health so
that you can start
to put some of that
information together for you.
AUDIENCE: Hi--
TAZ BHATIA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here.
I had a quick question about how
you approach that conversation
with older generations.
I think with parents and
grandparents sometimes
it can be harder to have
these types of conversations
and the education
background-- they're not
as, I guess open to changing
habits or lifestyle.
Have you had older clients
or can talk for experiences
where you've approached it with
parents or grandparents that
have been successful?
Or any tip for that?
TAZ BHATIA: Yeah,
what a great question.
I've experienced this
one personally, for sure.
We do have older patients
that come to the practice,
but they're typically
more engaged.
They've already done a little
bit of digging and research,
so they're a little
bit more open.
Now-- and within our
own family, my dad
doesn't listen to
anything I say.
He'll say, OK,
sweetheart, I'll do that.
And I'm sure he
doesn't do any of it.
So, they're tougher because
they come from the generation
of the doctor was right.
I'm going to do what the
doctor said and Pharma is best.
That's their generation.
So they believe-- and their
medicine is transactional.
You go to the doctor, you
get a script in your hand,
that visit is now complete.
If you did not get
a script in your,
there's no point to the visit.
So that's the generation
that they came from.
So it's much more challenging.
So the best way to start is two
or three things, I've noticed.
Like, hey, why don't you just
try doing these two things?
And not give them
too much information.
I've actually seen
the reverse work.
Like somebody our
age or younger,
they want the
information, they want
to understand how
everything connects.
They want to be empowered
and an advocate.
The older generation
doesn't want all that.
They don't care about the
connection and the big words
like inflammation
and oxidative stress.
They're not interested
in any of that.
All they want to know is
almost that same transactional
language.
Your joints hurt, try this.
And then you give
them two things to do.
And then you follow
back up, maybe
after, give them two weeks,
and see if after two weeks,
they were able to put those
two things into effect.
So I would think--
transactional is only word
that comes to my mind,
but simple commands.
This hurts, do this.
That's not working, try this.
Do this-- I've noticed
that anytime I sit with
my mother-in-law,
my mom, or my dad--
any of them.
And they're all so different
in their personalities.
But, essentially,
the conversation
always goes the same way.
Anytime I try to
connect the dots,
put the pieces of their health
together, explain all of this,
I lose / So, don't do that.
Just be very simple
and be very direct.
And see if they feel better.
And oftentimes
they'll get results.
And then that motivates
them to move on to step two
or to step three.
So try that.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Coming
for you, Grandma.
TAZ BHATIA: I know.
Tough!
Tough crowd.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
on, just, technology again.
So there are so
many apps now that
can track your steps, or
your workouts, or calories,
or turn down your the
blue light on your screen
after a certain time.
They have all these
different things.
So I guess, do you
any advice to me,
people in this room, who may
be designing apps like there?
Or for the rest of us who
use all of these things.
Like how to navigate it,
how to design better,
how to incorporate
a holistic thing?
Because I think
it, right now, it
gives almost a false
sense of control.
TAZ BHATIA: Security.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like, oh, well, like, my phone
told me to stand up today.
So, like, I'm great.
Like I'm on going on
a fitness journey.
TAZ BHATIA: That's
such a great question.
And I have seen that.
People rely on their data.
They come in the room
and they're like,
well, let me show you.
I know I'm getting REM sleep,
because my sleep tracker
says I'm getting REM sleep.
I'm like, why is your
sleep tracker in your room?
I see that all the time.
It's good and bad.
It's not all it's not
all either direction.
It's good because
you're getting data.
You're getting information.
You're getting sort of an
initial look at what you're
doing.
But it's bad because it's
not the whole picture.
That's the bad part.
So I think anyone
who's designing,
anytime they can design--
and I challenge
myself with this, too.
Anytime you can
design to where you're
trying to bring in the
whole picture in some form
or fashion.
If you're designing
a sleep tracker,
well maybe ask a few more
questions around sleep.
Just because they
checked off on they
got this many hours of REM
sleep does not necessarily
mean that they're healthy
or that all that sleep
quality was good.
So it may be working
with somebody
who has sort of this
well-rounded approach who
can bring more of the whole
picture into any of these.
And then take taking some of
these folks who are using data
and using apps
through workflows.
That if this is
happening, then you
may want to consider
this, this, and this.
Not turning into
a doctor's office,
necessarily, but, hey, have a
conversation with your doctor.
You might want to get
your labs checked.
Or you may need to
drink more water.
You know, whatever it is.
But having more
well-rounded approach,
where other than just fixating
on one or two data points,
is going to help the patient on
the other end of that be more
successful in the long run.
So I don't know if
that was helpful.
ARIEL ALTMAN: No,
it is interesting.
Because there are
so many different--
TAZ BHATIA: There are
so many right now.
ARIEL ALTMAN: --apps, now.
Just because you hit
your steps doesn't
mean that you're healthy.
[LAUGHING] At all.
TAZ BHATIA: It's a great way
to check in with yourself.
But it's not accomplishing,
like, who am I,
what are my main needs?
What do I need to build
under that main idea?
ARIEL ALTMAN: And I know you
went over it in the book.
But if I was going to go
get a blood test tomorrow,
what would be the two
or three top signals
that I should be looking for?
TAZ BHATIA: So, I mean I
can answer that very easily.
I think the number one thing
we're not taking for routinely,
which every doctor should be
checking every patient for,
are inflammation markers.
They're easy to do, they're
covered by insurance.
But checking like a CRP,
ESR, which is a sed rate,
and a homocysteine.
Those three things you should
be doing every six months.
Because to me, those are
the earliest warnings
that something is wrong with
your body and something's not
quite right.
And then the investigative
work can come after that.
So that's one.
For women, I think
it's so critical
to look at your hormone levels.
I talk about this all
throughout the book.
Looking at estrogen,
progesterone, thyroid.
The derivatives
of those hormones
because then it tells us what
your body's doing with them.
And you want to do
them periodically.
Because you want to track it.
Speaking of data, you want
to be able to track it.
Because what's normal for
you, is not normal for me.
So you know you might feel
really good at a TSH of two,
but I feel good at a TSH of one.
So when, five years from
now, you have a baby,
or something happens and your
TSH shifts and you're, quote
unquote, "normal" by
the conventional range,
but you feel like crap,
then we can go look back.
And say, oh, no,
no that's not where
your TSH needs to be for you.
So I think tracking
this data, tracking
these labs, that's the
beauty of technology,
is tracking it over the
course of your lifespan.
And knowing where you felt
great, where you didn't feel
so good.
And it also helps you
later when you guys enter
sort of the anti-aging
or, kind of,
the more prevention
conversation.
Because then we know where to
correct you back to, as well.
ARIEL ALTMAN: Totally.
I love it.
Well, thank you so much--
TAZ BHATIA: Thank you, fun.
ARIEL ALTMAN: --for coming.
I know we're all really excited.
So give an applause for Dr. Taz.
TAZ BHATIA: Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]